I think that when we
use love and compassion as our guiding
principles we can create
develop and Implement systems of change
that are beneficial to all sentient
beings and to the environment
now I've been
I've been a scoundrel in my life
I've been selfish I've been cruel at
times hard to work with and ungrateful
but so many of you in this room have
given me a second chance and I think
that's when we're at our best
when when we support each other not when
we cancel each other out for past
mistakes but when we help each other to
grow when we educate each other when we
guide each other towards Redemption that
is the best of humanity
when he was when he was when he was 17
my brother wrote this lyric he said run
to the rescue with love and peace will
follow thank you